j'ai été informé il hier soir du décès
d'un médecin hospitalier
c'est à ma connaissance avec toutes les
réserves que j'ai indiqué auparavant lié
au secret médical
c'est à ma connaissance la première
situation qui a frappé un médecin
hospitalier je n'en dirai pas plus
en raison du secret médical en raison de
la volonté de la famille de garder
aujourd'hui le secret autour de la
personne parce que le secret médical ne
s'arrête pas à la mort je ne vous
donnerai donc pas d'informations plus
précises que cela mais je fusse que vous
m'en donnez l'occasion je voudrais
vraiment m'associer à la douleur à la
peine de la famille à la douleur et à la
peine de l'ensemble des soignants est à
nouveau souligner le courage
extraordinaire dont font preuve
l'ensemble des médecins des soignants
des pompiers de toutes les personnes qui
permettent de sauver des vies chaque
jour il va très lourd tribut qui est
payé par là par la grande famille des
médecins aujourd'hui dans notre pays
mais ça veut dire olivier ferrand
qu'aujourd'hui les soignants qui sont
confrontés dans les établissements
hospitaliers ou en ville à des patients
atteints de corne à virus ne sont pas
suffisamment équipés protégés et peuvent
donc comme cela semble être le cas en
l'espèce contracté la maladie eux mêmes
ce que nous savons pour la france comme
pour les pays étrangers c'est que la
plupart des soignants qui vont
contracter la maladie virale ne vont pas
là contractés dans le cadre de leurs
missions hospitalières
mais en dehors des missions
hospitalières c'est pour ça par exemple
que nous mettons tout en oeuvre pour
pouvoir assurer des transports
individualisé pour des soignants dans
les hôpitaux dans les grandes métropoles
c'est pour ça que nous donnons aussi des
indications à l'ensemble des soignants
comme à l'ensemble des français sur le
respect des gestes barrières du lavage
des mains de la protection individuelle
et collective
que ce soit au travail ou en dehors du
travail mais oui il y a des soignants
qui sont par essence en première ligne
qui sont par définition ceux qui sont le
plus en contact avec les malades qui
avec ou sans protection d'ailleurs parce
qu'il ya plusieurs car nous avons eu une
discussion avec des médecins
réanimateurs d'un hôpital qui nous
faisait part de plusieurs cas de
contamination dans une unité de médecine
de médecin ou l'infirmier qui bien qu
équipés en masques avait pu être
contaminé
il y évidemment eu les équipes
action le matériel de protection le
maire le matériel de protection est
absolument indispensable pour les
soignants mais avec ou sans matériel de
protection lent avec vincent le fait
d'être on va en parler ou les malades
dans son exercice professionnel
on peut être malade quand on est
soignants